The perfect setup would be if it bounces
here and then fails and I get in short
as it breaks the lows. That would be a
great setup. It doesn't need to be much
of a pullback, even just like up to here
somewhere. Some kind of spike higher.
The ES is still grinding lower, which is
good. I'm really nervous and or not
nervous, but really just in my head just
thinking I'm just going to miss this.
It's just going to just going to go
without me and it's just going to grind
lower.
But again, I want to wait for my signal.
I haven't taken a trade in a while. So
there's some FOMO there. That's a tiny
bit of a higher a lower high, but really
that's just like a micro spike. I
wouldn't really say that's enough. I
need more than that. It's nice that it
made a new low.
So I feel like the fake lower flush has
happened and so we're now seeing if that
fails. I really don't want to get short
on that, but it's like I don't I won't I
don't really need that much more of a
pullback. So it's like do I just do it
and then have my stop kind of just up
here. I think I just want to wait one or
two more candles, see what it looks
like.
Cuz it looks like we might start a
bounce here.
Nothing to really know on a 5-minute
candlestick wise. It just looks like
we're kind of chopping at the top. ES
kind of looks the same. Okay, that's
enough of a spike higher. I would go
short if it made a new low. The ES
basically same thing. We basically have
a head and shoulders forming. It's
definitely making a head and shoulders
here. So I'm going to get short on this
if it breaks lower. Just waiting with my
order below this low. It'd be nice to
not get in on a huge spike lower, but
that's definitely a pullback that I
like.
It's kind of a funky head and shoulders,
but it's good showing good weakness. And
then we have nice target down here, 3x
to the open. Good signal. It's all that
matters. I was patient and waited. If it
pulls back on me, so be it. Stops in a
good spot. So you can kind of do is get
in when you get the signals and then let
the trade play out. I'm happy with how
patient I was there for really the
proper signal, I would say. Big picture
for targets, I mean I think going for
the open
is great. I'm just trying to give back
this move. That would be the ideal
thing. I don't if it gets going, you
know, we could get further down.
Um, you know, yesterday kind of that's
exactly what happened. We had a spike
up, sat there for a while and then sold
off to the open. Uh, and then clearly
continued lower.
I don't I I think that's unlikely that I
hold through that.
But always the possibility is always
there. And of course we could come down
and and tap this as support and continue
higher if we're going to stay in the
uptrend. So that's one thing to be aware
of. I think it'll just see how the trend
develops. Do we flush down really fast
and is it just worth to just jump out or
do we
you know, kind of go in a methodical
downtrend and I can manage
uh, my stops efficiently. I'd probably
only go break even once we kind of came
down here. So trade is going to do what
the trade is going to do at this point.
That's not a good spike lower. I mean
that makes me think I'm just going to
get stopped out. It's going to continue
higher, but
I mean I'm happy with the trade. I think
I waited for a good signal. If it was
going to go,
that's where it was going to go. That
was the good entry.
Um, you know, you can't control what the
market does after that.
All I controlled was my entry and my
entry was good. That's all that matters.
Okay, time to lock in. Looks like we're
starting to get movement. Um,
the level we've come down to is
you know, we're kind of we've pretty
much come down to yesterday's
um, chop range on the Nasdaq and the ES
has come down to yesterday's close.
Uh, and it looks like we're pretty much
at
the 10:00 a.m. reversal time. Nice
spike.
Trend, spike again and then it tried to
keep going lower and it looks like it's
failing.
I want to see it take out this swing
high right here.
That confirms to me that it's starting
to make new highs
that are higher. So that kind of
confirms some uptrend for me. So that's
confirmed now. The last thing I want to
see is a pullback. I want to see it
essentially come down to here, maybe
retest this high and then
um, I'll look to jump in a long off of
that, you know, maybe if it if it pulls
down to here. Um, and then I'll jump in
long after that cuz I want to see
essentially a really confirmed uptrend.
ES is basically acting the same. It's a
little bit tighter. It hasn't sold off
as much.
But there's good alignment there. So I
think we have a good potential. It's
basically made a double bottom here.
Um, I just want to see a pullback here
and then um, I'm going to look to get
long on the Nasdaq here with the idea
that on a you know, on a 5-minute is
we've got really nice
fair value gaps from this morning,
especially this opening sell-off. That's
this.
Um, and I think big picture,
you know, big picture looking at a
15-minute chart for the ES or the
Nasdaq, we're in this
we're in this uptrend, you know, this is
this could literally just be a pullback.
Doesn't look as strong on the Nasdaq,
but the ES for sure um, it's just kind
of in this
uptrend. So it looks like it could just
be pulling back to here and going
higher.
Um, and the Nasdaq has
you know, made a good flush lower, too,
but I think overall is
uh, on the bullish side as well. So
let's see what this pullback right here
plays out. I would like a little bit
more of a pullback than this one
candlestick.
Um, getting long off of that just feels
a little aggressive. Even if it, you
know,
it could poke up here one more time
and do a bigger pullback. That's fine.
Because of this choppiness,
um,
I want to be careful here. It'd be
perfect if it pulled back. I think down
to here would be a little better cuz
that's much more of a a real attempt to
go lower versus this is kind of like,
okay, it's a little pullback. It is kind
of hitting this, which does look good.
And the ES here is looking to make new
highs. It does look good though. I I
Personally, I kind of would like a
little bit more of a spike lower, but I
could
put my stop all the way down here. I
want to see how this new high acts. Does
it just hit that and then flush lower?
Or does it kind of hold that? It's
always super hard waiting for this
pullback right here cuz it feels like
it's just going to go up and I'm going
to miss it. And it I got to just accept
if it does that, that's okay. I want to
wait for this pullback cuz if this pulls
back and rips up, I think that looks
solid. And also this is where, okay,
this would just sell off if it's going
to I'm avoiding the loss by waiting for
this. ES is selling off. It's a good
retest kind of candle. If it reverses
that, I think that's solid. I'm going to
put a an order up here cuz if it does
just reverse that and break that high,
I'm okay getting in before the
candlestick closes.
Ideally, it would close here and then
push and after even if a little
pullback.
Cuz getting in on kind of a flush higher
is kind of scary sometimes
just with how the market can be. Looks
like we're in long. I would like to
target the open, but it's hard to know
what the market's going to do. Got nice
potential on a 5-minute for this to rip
up. Just got to let it play out now. I
think the potential's there. If it chops
around, it chops around. I did
everything um,
good for entry that is in my control.
You know, waited for the pullback. Nice
signal. Now I just have to let the
market play out. Depending on what this
this move looks like, you know, I'll
manage and either get out at 3x or
um, you know,
size scale uh, trail up my stop. But I'm
not going break even until it probably
comes up here somewhere. Looks like I
chose the right market this morning. If
you look at the ES, it's it's not even
moving yet. Would have entered in here
and it would have been I would have been
down. So that's
Ideally, we need both to get moving
though. The the ES needs to be
at least come up to here. That'll help
push up the Nasdaq more. So just got to
let things play out. I think the the
swings look good for the long side. The
ES looks like it's just kind of
struggling to break through the
overnight swing here. This is the part
where you just got to be patient and do
nothing. Just got to let the the market
play out. Even though sometimes I wish I
could just click a fast forward button
cuz it kind of just sucks waiting
for your fate to be decided. That's a
pretty gross candlestick
if it doesn't get gobbled up pretty
instantly. That could be a bad sign.
Hopefully it got it gets gobbled up. We
could there could be a s- uptrend right
here, but that's a pretty big bearish
rip lower. It kind of makes it seem like
we're going to make a new low or just
make one more flush lower before it
reverses. That is crappy. I don't know
if I want to stay longer and see if this
I think the it would have gone up here
if it was going to go up, even if it was
like this. And so it making a new kind
of stab lower here, even if it, you
know, bounces here and does eventually
go up,
it's, you know, my read is essentially
off and it's not acting how I am
seeing it and so usually I find it's
better to just call it for the day
and not try and take more trades on a
day where the market's not acting how
you would envision it to act. Just
because it makes it harder and less
likely for a trade to actually work out.